voici la bataille de l'année que nous avons
créée, mais maintenant une équipe américaine l'
a gagnée au cours des 15 dernières années. Je veux que
vous entraîniez mon
équipe, nous nous entraînons 12 heures par jour, tous les jours,
faites-le correctement, rien dans votre vie ne
sera jamais le meilleur.  le même choix vous appartient car
en ce moment en Corée
Japon France Russie partout dans le monde les
gars s'entraînent 24h/24 et 7j/7 car ils veulent
gagner la bataille de l'
année l'année prochaine nous avons la France nous
avons l'Allemagne nous avons l'Italie
Russ  nous, les Brésiliens et bien sûr les
favoris, les Coréens, tout se résume
à une chose, comment ça fait d'être une
équipe, ce sont les Jeux olympiques de notre sport
[Applaudissements]
messieurs, ce ne sont pas les mêmes gars
qui ont franchi votre porte le premier
jour de la bataille de  l'année en
3D